Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera.
Quante volte non troviamo le parole
per dire quello che sentiamo?
Quante volte le parole e la realtà
sembrano staccate?
E soprattutto per noi femmine,
quante volte non siamo
nelle cose che diciamo,
in una specie di mancato
appuntamento con noi stesse?
E in questo mancato appuntamento,
c'entrano le parole?
Si, c'entrano; perché migliore è
il nostro uso delle parole,
migliore è la nostra presa sulla realtà,
perché le parole sono potentissime.
Le parole la creano, la realtà,
e la realtà coincide
con il racconto che ne facciamo.
Tempo fa è uscita una ricerca
che sostiene che gli uomini
pronunciano 7000 parole al giorno,
e le donne 20000.
È vero.
Ma la vera questione è: perché?
Perché abbiamo bisogno di più parole,
per dire quello che sentiamo?
Può essere che maschi e femmine
non abbiamo lo stesso modo
di intendere una parola?
E che molto di quello
che quella parola significa per noi
resta fuori da quella definizione?
E può essere soprattutto che qui sotto,
cioè sotto quello di cui sto parlando,
si nasconde una forza
inespressa, e nascosta,
che va ben oltre le parole?
È su queste domande,
che quasi trent'anni fa
ho incontrato Giovanna Galletti.
Io sono regista a Roma -
ero, nel senso in quel momento -
Giovanna economista a Milano.
Quindi due mondi.
Avevamo due vite felici,
il lavoro che avevamo scelto andava bene;
eppure quella mancanza,
quel mancato appuntamento con noi stesse
era molto presente.
Lei, esperta della lingua
dell'astrazione, l'economia,
in cerca di risposte
che quella lingua stentava a dare.
Io esperta dello spostamento
del punto di vista,
che cercavo di raccontare
l'invisibile, senza riuscirci.
A quel punto abbiamo unito
i nostri desideri, le nostre competenze,
e abbiamo deciso
di far nascere qualcosa da lì.
Prima ci sono stati dieci anni
di studio appassionato con altre,
e poi il salto.
Nel 2001 ci ha unito quell'emozione
che quel disagio che sentivamo
nominava qualcosa di nuovo,
a cui andava dato un nome,
e nel 2001 abbiamo fondato Labodif.
Che cos'è Labodif?
Significa "Laboratorio della Differenza",
ed è il primo istituto italiano
specializzato proprio
nella differenza fra maschi e femmine.
È un istituto di Ricerca Sociale,
di Formazione e di Comunicazione.
Differenza, quella tra maschi e femmine,
essenziale e preziosissima;
eppure io e Giovanna
siamo state per una vita
fra quelle che consideravano
che contasse solo l'individuo,
che nascere cioè maschio o femmina
fosse un dettaglio trascurabile.
Ma non è affatto così perché la realtà,
così come le parole, non è neutra.
Eravamo a Sarzana qualche anno fa,
in un seminario organizzato
da psichiatri e psichiatre
che ci avevano chiesto un approfondimento
sul tema della salute mentale
e della differenza.
Perché lo cito?
Perché quella è stata la prima volta
in cui noi abbiamo
fatto fare un esercizio.
Pensateci anche voi.
"Esiste una parola, la stessa parola,
che nella vostra esperienza,
a seconda che a pronunciarla
sia un maschio o una femmina,
cambia di significato?"
C'è stato un silenzio,
e poi un uomo ha alzato la mano
e ha detto "Io ce l'ho,
è la parola niente".
Quando qualcuno mi domanda "Cosa hai?",
ed io rispondo "Niente",
intendo niente;
quando mi capita di tornare a casa
e chiedere a mia moglie "cosa hai?"
e lei risponde "Niente",
sta dicendo "Ho talmente
tante cose da dirti,
che è meglio che io stia zitta".
Abbiamo fatto questo esercizio
più di una volta,
anzi continuiamo sempre a farlo.
In un liceo romano,
quindi ragazzi di 16-17 anni,
un ragazzo alzò la mano
e disse: "La parola dolore.
Quando la pronuncio io, mi sento debole.
Quando la pronuncia una ragazza,
sembra sia forza".
Allora si è aggiunta una ragazza
che ha detto: "Io aggiungo
la parola 'scusa'.
Quando la pronuncia un ragazzo
è la fine di un discorso;
quando la pronuncio io
è l'inizio di un discorso".
Praticamente tutte le parole
che conosciamo
hanno questa, quantomeno
possibile, doppia natura.
E studiare le parole, e la differenza,
è una cosa molto seria,
capace non solo di cambiare
gli equilibri famigliari, personali,
ma sociali.
In cosa consiste
lo studio della differenza?
Consiste nello svelare alle femmine
qual è la nostra specificità
e a viverla non come un difetto
ma come una cosa bella;
e agli uomini a insegnare la parzialità,
cioè sentirsi parte di un universo,
e non l'intero universo.
Perché noi viviamo in un mondo
apparentemente neutro, universale,
quantomeno qui in occidente,
cioè valido per tutti e per tutte;
ma nella realtà è costruito
su caratteristiche simboliche
prevalenti maschili.
E questa cosa funziona così:
noi nasciamo, pensate, dal maschile
e questa idea entra nella nostra testa
e - userò un'espressione forte -
ci colonizza.
Vivere in un ordine simbolico
che non ci rappresenta
significa vivere da ospiti,
e l'ospite chiede permesso.
Quali sono le conseguenze
di vivere da ospite?
Che possiamo pronunciare, noi femmine,
parole o espressioni che contraddicono
la nostra stessa esperienza
senza neppure accorgerci.
Eccola, "Aspettare un bambino".
Ero da un'amica incinta,
e l'ho vista e le ho detto: "che succede?"
e lei m'ha detto "Aspetto un bambino".
Ed io le ho detto "Ma davvero aspetti? ".
"In che senso?".
"Davvero aspetti o il corpo cambia,
si gonfia, hai nausea,
felicità improvvise, tempeste ormonali,
la sensazione ineludibile e profondissima
che stai costruendo una vita
dentro il tuo corpo?".
Non dimenticherò mai
di averle visto spuntare una lacrima.
"E chi è che aspetta?".
"Il padre e tutti gli altri, ma non te".
Noi pronunciamo espressioni
che contraddicono quello che sentiamo,
senza accorgercene.
E questa è una cosa grave,
perché significa cancellazione
di un modo differente
di guardare la realtà
che aiuterebbe la realtà ad andare meglio.
Ero in una scuola elementare, sono entrata
e ho detto come faccio sempre:
"Buongiorno, bambini e bambine".
Non so se avete presente la sensazione
che sto provando io stasera
di quando si parla in un contesto pubblico
e chi parla, se vuole, può sintonizzarsi
su questa cosa che si crea fra me e voi,
come un'area solida.
Ogni volta che pronunciavo
la parola "bambine",
sentivo un movimento impercettibile
eppure presente della classe,
sentivo le bambine tirarsi un po' su.
Alla fine del discorso avevano
la schiena dritta.
Erano nel discorso.
Dunque c'erano.
Che cosa vuol dire questo?
Vuol dire che questa cancellazione
riguarda il modo in cui noi viviamo,
pensiamo, desideriamo, amiamo,
viviamo la giornata, la salute.
È una cosa talmente invisibile
da non essere percepita
neanche dalle persone
che sono soggetto di questa cosa.
E allora noi cosa facciamo?
Riscriviamo le parole, è semplice.
E una delle parole
che vorremmo riscrivere stasera
è questa, inadeguatezza.
Che cos'è l'inadeguatezza?
È la sensazione più diffusa
nella popolazione femminile.
Come la possiamo definire?
"Non sentirsi abbastanza,
malgrado i risultati raggiunti".
L'inadeguatezza è una sensazione
così diffusa e trasversale -
alle carriere, alla formazione,
alle condizioni sociali -
da costituire un tema sociale,
tant'è che imprese e aziende
non fanno altro che organizzare corsi
per indagare il fenomeno.
Ma come lo indagano?
Provando a diminuire, o eliminare,
la sensazione di inadeguatezza.
Noi pensiamo, invece,
che la sensazione di inadeguatezza
sia il primo segnale di differenza,
il primo segnale di indomità.
E quindi va riscritta questa parola.
Perché se io mi sento inadeguata,
e colgo il significato
dell'ordine che viviamo,
proverò a rimediare all'errore.
Il problema è che quell'errore sono io,
e quindi proverò a cancellarmi.
L'inadeguatezza, quando noi andiamo
a guardarla nel vocabolario,
significa questo: insufficiente,
sproporzionato, fuori misura,
non conforme al soggetto.
Non so se le donne in sala lo sanno,
la sensazione di sentirsi
troppo, o troppo poco,
credo sia una cosa che conoscete.
Ecco, il "non conforme al soggetto":
il soggetto non sono io,
quindi è normale sentirmi
non conforme al soggetto.
Qual è il problema?
È che noi tendiamo a dire, subito dopo:
"non vado bene, non sono abbastanza,
devo fare di più, devo fare meglio".
Invece l'unica cosa che dovremmo fare
è mettere in discussione il criterio
su cui si è formata quella parola.
Tant'è che noi amiamo riscriverla così:
In/adeguatezza.
L'in/adeguatezza è il primo germoglio
di qualcosa di buono.
Quindi sentirsi inadeguate
è una cosa buona,
bisogna da lì provare a risignificare
e poi diventare la partenza
di un'esistenza femminile felice.
Noi non ci limitiamo
a risignificare le parole -
e, parentesi, risignificare
non vuol dire sostituire.
Risignificare vuol dire affiancare,
al significato che già c'è,
un significato che tenga conto
della nostra esperienza.
Ci piace inventarne di parole,
e questa è la parola di stasera:
Madrità.
Conoscete certamente la "maternità",
che è la condizione per cui una donna
sta per mettere al mondo una creatura.
Immagino che conosciate,
o possiate immaginare,
cosa vuol dire la "mammità",
cioè essere sempre a disposizione,
che la propria vita viene sempre
in secondo, terzo, quarto, quinto luogo.
La "Madrità" invece, che cos'è?
È scegliere figure di donne autorevoli,
madri simboliche,
la cui esperienza autorizzi la mia,
perché vivendo in un ordine simbolico
che non mi rappresenta
ho bisogno di un modello.
Non so se conoscete - credo di sì -
Whoopy Goldberg,
un'attrice americana, nera.
Lei racconta spesso questo episodio.
È nel salotto di casa sua, ha nove anni
e sta guardando
una puntata di "Star Trek".
Ad un certo punto,
vede apparire sullo schermo
la tenente Uhura,
tenente in quarto grado
della navicella spaziale,
nera e femmina come lei.
E lei dice: "A quella vista,
ho cominciato ad andare
in giro per la casa
dicendo: "Mamma, venite, venite tutti.
In televisione c'è una nera
che non fa la cameriera".
E subito dopo dice:
"In quel momento, ho sentito
che avrei potuto diventare
qualunque cosa volessi diventare".
Altro esempio, Oprah Winfrey.
Anche lei molto conosciuta,
anche lei nera.
Lei racconta che leggendo
un libro di Maya Angelou,
poeta nera americana,
la prima invitata nella cerimonia
di insediamento presidenziale, nel '93,
da Bill Clinton,
ecco, leggendo un libro che si intitola
"Io so perché l'uccello in gabbia canta"
dice: "In quelle pagine,
per la prima volta ho incontrato
me stessa per intero".
Ma come è possibile incontrare sé stesse,
per intero, nelle parole di un'altra?
E poi, subito dopo, aggiunge:
"Per la prima volta sentivo
la mia esperienza di ragazzina nera
rappresentata, convalidata e autorizzata".
La Madrità è questo:
qualcuna che vive per conto suo, fa cose,
e chi la guarda,
e in quel momento si mette
nella posizione di figlia simbolica,
sa che può.
Non riguarda solamente
né le figure pubbliche né le donne nere,
anche se ho usato due esempi
di donne nere:
riguarda tutte noi.
Io ne ho tante di madri,
e stasera voglio nominarne una.
Si chiama Carla Lonzi.
Non credo che la conosciate,
perché non è conosciutissima,
ma è una donna che ha fatto
la critica d'arte negli anni '70,
di grande successo,
era destinata a diventare
la critica d'arte del suo tempo.
Tanti degli artisti diventati famosi
devono al suo libro,
"Autoritratto", la loro fama.
Lei, ad un certo punto,
nel '70 lascia tutto.
E dice: "Ci dovrà pur essere qualcuno
che si occupa, per mestiere,
di cosa vuole dire essere una femmina".
E in una frase bellissima
che dice "lasciare era niente,
rispetto al dolore di tradire me stessa",
fa questa scelta.
Vedere lei ha autorizzato me,
che ho fatto la stessa scelta,
e quindi stasera la ricordo.
Chissà dov'è, perché non c'è più.
Mai come adesso serve un numero di donne
consapevoli di essere Altro,
e capaci di conoscere cos'è,
questo Altro, e di viverlo.
Mai come adesso servono donne
capaci di non mancare
l'appuntamento con sé stesse,
e mi auguro che stasera le mie parole
abbiano mosso in alcune, spero in tutte,
lo stesso mio e nostro desiderio
di vivere in presenza.
Perché la realtà, anche se fanno di tutto
per farci credere che è così,
non è data una volta per tutte.
La realtà, come la lingua, si trasforma.
E quindi un mondo così,
un mondo fatto di donne e uomini
consapevoli di appartenere
a due ordini simbolici differenti,
quello si, a mio giudizio,
porta bellezza e futuro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)